no one's buying the Democrat lying on
this and it's coming out in the polls
and even the corporate propagandists
over at MSNBC they can't hide it MSNBC
and NBC uh here's Chuck Todd with some
new polling data digging deeper here
we've got some all-time midterm highs
that should serve as red flags for the
Democrats the wrong track 71 percent
all-time midterm High since we've been
polling how about presidential approved
disapproval on the economy sitting at 57
percent again we hadn't recorded that uh
ever that high in our poll and the third
one the direction of the economy and the
next Shares are going to get better or
worse 50 percent say it's going to get
worse again an all-time high in midterm
polling okay so I want to focus on the
first number he read out there which was
71 polled say we're on the the wrong
track now you guys again you know my
feelings about polls and I think this
often Bears out after elections they end
up being wildly off or they'll tell you
this person this group of people were
misrepresented or a certain amount of
these people don't pick up their phones
or whatever it might be so you have to
take a sum of this with a grain of salt
but the trends are getting so out of
control now and they're becoming and the
gaps are so obvious that there really is
something going on here might I also
recommend you know just talk to your
friends and family are people even even
left-leaning people even Democrats are
they going boy things aren't really
going well right now it feels like
Biden's on the ball and we're safe and
they're we're not going to nuclear war
and Armageddon and you know all of the
stuff
so if you don't want to just trust polls
go to that but the number that I want to
focus on is that 71 say we're on the
wrong track that strikes me as a really
really crazy number we were told that
Joe Biden got 81 million votes old Joe
Biden who didn't do any rallies who you
couldn't find anyone that really
supported him except the media loved him
and you know sort of big Tech loved him
and they had to take out orange man 81
million people voted for this guy and
now 71 percent of people polled are
saying the country's going in the wrong
direction that that the bottom is
falling out I think that is the phrase
one might use on that this guy is in a
lot of trouble and everyone sees it he
is the sacrificial lamb and they will
take him out one way or another after
the midterms that is obvious he's dead
man walking I don't know if he can see
it or not because he's so muddled we'll
get uh we'll get to more on that in just
a minute but the Democrats are in a lot
of trouble and the numbers bear it out